اذا مشاهدينا كما تستمعون صور مباشره الان
من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم صوت الرصاص
يدوي مره اخرى بعد ان شهدنا فتره من
الهدوء الحذر اذا هي مواجهات عسكريه
اندلعت منذ الصباح بين القوات الدعم
السريع برئاسه حمتي
والجيش السوداني
بقياده عبد الفتاح البرهان ما يزال صوت
الرصاص اذا يدوي في العاصمه الخرطوم هناك
تضارب في البيانات وكل طرف يدعي السيطره
على مواقع حيويه في
العاصمه الخرطوم
اذن كما نستمع معكم مشاهدينا على المباشر
اذا صوت الرصاص يدوي اذا الان في الخرطوم
والمعلومات تشير على ان اطلاق النار هذا
هو في محيط مقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه في العاصمه السودانيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات